[Dan] What you’re looking at is a story.
It’s a story about numbers, it’s a story
about people, and it’s a story about how
numbers and people interact.
It’s a story about World of Warcraft, in
specific, but it’s also a story about every
video game, in a way a story about video games
themselves.
It’s a story about why it’s rude to be
bad at World of Warcraft.
It’s December 2004.
Massively Multiplayer Online Role Playing
Game World of Warcraft is taking the world
by storm and Wallace, the Gnome Rogue walks
barefoot through Molten Core.
Wallace, a proper hobbit of a gnome, doesn’t
wear shoes, and he’s not in a hurry to get
anywhere.
His guild thinks this is a little embarrassing,
but it mostly just makes for a story about
a quirky weirdo they met in this new video
game.
Ultimately they enjoy having Wallace around
because he makes the game fun.
Six months later they’re screaming at Wallace
and demanding that he equip some boots.
Ultimatums are dropped, tempers are elevated,
and no one’s having a good time.
Someone calls Wallace a bad player.
No one disagrees.
[Gentle music]
[Choice] ‘Instrumental play’ was first
described by literary theorist Wolfgang Iser
in his 1993 essay “The Fictive and the Imaginary.”
Iser, a highly influential theorist, saw play
as being divided cleanly into the categories
of free and instrumental based on how the
act of playing related to goals.
On one hand is play unburdened by systematized
goals and on the other hand, play with goals.
In Iser’s framework play becomes instrumental
the moment it has some intended outcome, something
resembling rules and structure.
However in Iser’s work this was largely
to distinguish between children chasing each
other around a field for no reason other than
because it felt fun in the moment, and children
chasing each other in a game of football with
concrete winners and losers.
Its discussion in relation to video games
is credited to sociologist T.L Taylor in her
2006 book Play Between Worlds.
‘Instrumental play is a goal-oriented approach
that values efficiency, expertise and optimizing
strategies as part of play.
In instrumental play, the point of playing
is not to reach the end, but to find the best
way of getting there.’
This is, for the record, not a discussion
of good players as opposed to bad players,
we are talking about the ways you play the
game in which ‘being good’ is considered
desirable.
This is a critical distinction, and perhaps
if there’s going to be one takeaway from
all this it is this confrontation: the idea
that ‘being good at a game is a good thing’,
that the correct way of playing a game is
one in which you are good at the game, isn’t
some natural force of reality, but an imposed
value.
If you’ve ever gotten destroyed in a video
game and felt awful about it, just ashamed
of how hard you got thumped, that feeling
isn’t objective or natural, it is an instrumental
value that you are imposing on yourself.
[Dan] It's common for instrumental play to
be framed in opposition to fun, that they
are ends of a spectrum.
This is understandable in no small part because
instrumental play tends towards optimization,
which can often result in deeply un-fun player
behaviors.
This gets extended out to the extreme where
play framed around challenge or investment
is treated as irrational or somehow less genuine
than some hypothetically more “pure”,
“innocent”, “unadulterated” version
of play unconcerned with doing well.
It’s important in this conversation to establish,
firmly, that this is a false dichotomy.
We are going to spend a lot of time talking
about how fun gets optimized out of games,
which is why I want to stress that they are
not antithetical concepts.
Rather than being in conflict with one another
they are instead in tension: there is not
an opposed relationship, but there is a complex
one.
Because if you back up and think about it,
it’s easy to appreciate how someone can
find a deep enjoyment in improving at a skill,
or achieving goals, or discovering solutions
to complex problems.
Rather, instrumental play, play focused on
goals, can be juxtaposed with free play, the
form of play that is without ending.
Neither free or instrumental play can exist
in their purest form, but René Glas in his
book Battlefields of Negotiation describes
play in World of Warcraft as movement between
instrumental and free play.
For every arena match or dungeon, there is
a time before and afterward when you’re
waiting in town and just stand there, aimless.
This moment, this is free play approaching
its pure form.
An important consideration here is that game
design can rarely compel the player to take
action.
A game can attempt to prescribe an action,
such as the famous ‘press F to pay respects’,
but players tend to chafe against moments
like this, as in clumsy hands they tend to
come off as naive or insincere or, in the
language of the youth, cringe.
If you refuse to pay your respects then that’s
it, the game doesn’t even end so much as
it just bricks, a standoff between you and
a choice that doesn’t exist.
Whether or not you close the application,
if you refuse to pay your respects you functionally
stop playing the game.
World of Warcraft offers players a tremendous
amount of agency.
It is, after all, an entire virtual world.
You are, indeed, broadly free to not pay your
respects and the game is generally cool with
that.
You can shun levels, talent trees, and even
weapons and still play the game for a very,
very long time in a way that’s still identifiably
play.
Why shouldn’t you stand facing a wall on
the far side of Bloodmyst Isle and contemplate
the nature of the Draenei… forever?
Roleplaying is a genuine example of the value
of free play, and the fuzzy edges of instrumental
play.
Roleplayers engage with World of Warcraft
in a fundamentally different way than how
you or I might engage with it.
They are often less concerned with the explicit
objectives of World of Warcraft, and instead
prefer emergent activities.
By shunning the game’s progression system,
there’s a clear embrace of free play here.
but when roleplayers self-direct, say, by
holding an annual festival that raises tens
of thousand dollars of charity year after
year, they are creating their own goals and
that morphs into a form of instrumental play.
In this sense, you cannot have free and instrumental
play in their purest forms.
You might be surprised just how much of the
study of WoW is concerned with roleplaying,
because it reflects a fascinating alternative,
and socially-driven, means of engaging with
a game.
And that nuance, that question of how you
can enable a form of play that, by definition,
doesn’t concern itself with, like, the numbers,
the spreadsheets, the statistics, all the
stuff that the game is fundamentally made
of, that is awesome.
Blizzard can’t force you to stop staring
at the wall, but they can encourage and discourage
certain play practices and very rarely abolish
them in their entirety.
In Battlefields of Negotiation, Glas’s core
insight is that Blizzard is not an omnipotent
god in the World of Warcraft, the developers
are not the Arbiter.
Yes, they have immense influence and a form
of final say, but they are ultimately a stakeholder
who push their vision of the game, which either
aligns or resists against the playerbase.
Writing on Lineage II, Professor of Informatics
Constance Steinkuhler described MMOs as defined
by a “mangle of play”, the push and pull
relationship between game developers and their
players.
Blizzard has access to certain tools and means
of creating the “legitimate” World of
Warcraft experience, they have control over
the servers and decide what bespoke content
gets made and implemented, but they are not
the sole hand attempting to sculpt the game
MMOs are “interactively stabilized” systems,
coevolutionary, the emergent result of the
intersection of designers, armed with their
technology, and players, armed with their
own practices.
Blizzard has code, the players have codes
of practices.
Social codes of practice are ‘the tenets
laid down by individuals within the game who
have no design power or automatically conferred
authority.’
These social codes are often linked with perceptions
of ‘foul play’ and the ‘spirit of the
game’.
But they go far beyond that, and can shape
what is considered legitimate play in World
of Warcraft.
In Leet Noobs, Mark Chen sees success in World
of Warcraft as dynamically defined.
To be good at World of Warcraft is defined
by consensus.
Put another way, you are good if you do enough
of the things that we collectively decided
that good players do.
Success is relative and socially defined.
For a simple example, arena rating was very
inflated in Season 2 of Shadowlands.
While a typical season tends to have a median
rating around 1600, season one was severely
deflated with a median rating of 1426.
Some behind the scenes tweaking leading into
season 2 resulted in a median of roughly 1750.
In the abstract both of these are fine, the
actual underlying mechanics of matchmaking
are all relative, the numbers are arbitrary.
If you are a high level competitor the experience
on a match-to-match basis is generally the
same regardless of what the median rating
is, the shape of the curve remains the same,
it’s just shifted upwards.
The hitch is that certain rewards, like titles,
achievements, and armor, are hard coded to
specific ratings.
So the inflation resulted in the prestige
rewards being available to more players than
usual, many of whom would never have qualified
for it under different circumstances.
This led to a rather vocal belief that these
rewards were illegitimate, they ‘didn’t
count’.
Despite the game layer presenting these dragons
as equivalent, there is a significant difference
in their social value.
For Glas, World of Warcraft is composed of
various ‘idocultures’, groups of players
linked together by particular systems of knowledge,
beliefs, behaviors and customs.
Big boy raiders and roleplayers have totally
different ways of engaging with the world,
there is no single objective way to approach
WoW.
These idiocultures exist in layers.
You’ve got WoW players categorically, PvP
versus PvE, Battlegrounds versus Arenas, Keystones
versus Raids, Guilds, individual guilds, and
of course cliques within those guilds, and
players can move seamlessly between all of
these different modes, all of these different
ideocultures.
These different idiocultures may subscribe
to different social practices, and it is the
interaction between these groups and the constant
negotiation on proper codes of practice that
Glas argues shapes World of Warcraft.
It is the interaction between different groups
of people that set the boundaries and fundamental
meaning of play.
Instrumental play has entrenched itself as
the dominant mode of engagement with World
of Warcraft.
Through social codes of practice, players
are subject to expectations that they may
be completely unaware of.
It is taken as value neutral, and objectively
true, that expertise and success are the natural
objectives of play, and thus the default mode
of play that players owe to those around them.
In other words: It’s bad manners to be bad
at Warcraft.
[Choice] We’re going to talk for a moment
about the Great Vault.
If you play World of Warcraft then you probably
already know how it functions, and if you
don’t then all you need to know is this;
at the end of every week you get to pick one
reward from a grid that fills up as you do
specific group activities.
Options are dictated by difficulty and volume.
Do more stuff, get more picks.
Do higher difficulty stuff, get stronger picks.
Case study A: during the Shadowlands Season
3 race-to-world-first, in the US 2nd guild
BDGG, our players were required to fill all
9 slots to their maximum potency on multiple
‘mirror’ mains.
Since there is an element of luck to gearing
up, the top players will prepare multiple
copies of the same class in order to have
a few pulls at the slot machine and maximize
the chances of a favorable outcome.
For this particular raid tier, our Moonkin
player prepared three separate Druids, our
Death Knight raider prepared four Death Knights,
each of these characters had the same odds
of being the main character, based hugely
on the outcome of their Vault rewards.
These are players who are paid, in dollars,
for their time as part of a pseudo-professional
eSports event.
Achieving the absolute optimum performance
in a raid environment is part of their literal
job description.
This expectation was only maintained until
the progression period was over, at which
point no one cared, job’s done, do what
you want.
Case study B: Venture, US rank 180th.
They are a 2 night a week guild that has some
very different ideas.
If you’ll allow us this one indulgence,
let’s just take a moment to dunk on an incredibly
stupid opinion.
If some of this goes over your head, don’t
worry about it.
I promise you will pick up the important parts.
So it’s Season 3 of Shadowlands, almost
3 months into a 4 month season.
Our good friend and contributor to the show,
Crystal, has just come back to the game after
a lengthy break, so we spin up a group and
spend a few hours hanging out and doing dungeons.
In terms of gear, Crystal is wearing old junk
and so the rest of us have elected to bring
alts.
But a member of our group, the tastefully
named Moistrainbow, opts to bring his main
character, in part to make it easy but also
to fill out slots in his aforementioned vault.
Moistrainbow is doing this for a chance at
one specific item, the coveted Unbound Changeling.
This is one of the best trinkets in the game
for healers and casters at this point in time.
We end up doing over eight keys, but only
about four of them at level 15.
Moistrainbow does not do any other keys for
the week.
So, at the end of the week, this is what his
vault looks like.
He has 3 chances at the Unbound Changeling,
two will be at the maximum possible level.
The Changeling is 1 of 91 potential items.
Huh.
That’s good right?
That’s good.
Having consulted the team, a player getting
their Best-in-Slot trinket is good.
But Venture felt differently.
They came down on Moist hard for not maxing
out that final slot.
There was explicit shaming, snarky remarks,
even cowardly announcements from leadership
about players needing to do their part for
the team.
And perhaps on the face of it, you’re empathetic
to all that.
But we have been pissed off about this incident
for almost six months, so just give us a minute.
Remember, this was a piece of gear generated
solely for Moistrainbow, this is not typical
loot drama, there was no alternate home for
this trinket.
The issue was entirely in the missed opportunity
at a stronger version.
Gear in Warcraft is comprised of stats that
are assigned based on the individual item’s
overall budget, dictated by its slot and by
its level.
These stats all do and mean a lot of different
things.
So the ultimate unit of measurement we use
to value a piece of gear is to calculate its
contribution to the player’s damage.
How do we do that?
Easy, we build a robot to play our character
perfectly while wearing both items, ideally
a couple of thousand times, and then compare
the results.
Typically, a higher item level should translate
to a better item.
However, trinkets are not like other pieces
of gear, their item level can be deceptive.
A trinket lives or dies on its effect.
So this Unbound Changeling was the best possible
trinket with an item level of 272, down 6
item level from the max.
If we compare simulation results from a Destruction
Warlock at the time, we can see the difference
is barely perceptible on the graph.
This particular simulation values the overall
impact at 0.6%.
Here are some more details on that if you
are interested.
But we’ve buried the lead on this, because
Moistrainbow isn’t a Warlock, he’s a god
damn healer.
And healers are a whole different deal.
Healers don’t have the same simple, tangible
benefit from gear as damage-dealers receive.
For well over a decade, it has been standard
practice for guilds to starve their healers
of gear, on the basis that they don’t really
need it.
We don’t have any real way to even quantify
this difference for a healer.
While this would not be accurate at all, let’s
be generous and assume it would match this
point-six percent figure.
This was in the context of a guild that was
9 weeks behind the progression curve, working
on bosses that had been hit with the nerf
bat several times.
And just for those in the know, these people
were six healing Mythic Lords of Dread in
early June - like…
I don’t even have the words.
Gear was not their problem.
So a close friend of mine was bullied and
excluded from this group for not spending
a few more hours running dungeons to load
the bases for a one-percent chance at a maybe
half-percent increase in performance, where
that improvement was entirely disconnected
from the problems the group was encountering.
The reason we wanted to talk about this is
that I sincerely could not imagine a more
petty reason to give someone a hard time in
World of Warcraft.
Frankly, It's pathetic.
This was not an instrumental practice, this
was a social one.
Here, the social value of the item level was
wildly disproportionate to any tangible, mathematical
value.
The process of completing the necessary 8
keystones was a ritualistic reaffirmation
of commitment to the group.
The fact that the trinket was worth something
was just a pretense to enforce the practice.
[Dan] Early attempts at anthropological studies
of virtual worlds were fraught.
Some might look back on them as hopelessly
naive, but I prefer to categorize them as
bad.
Many of them sought to reify online spaces,
to rope them off from reality and paint them
as a separate self-sustaining world, an actual
destination as disconnected from the rest
of reality as the moon or perhaps Australia.
In Coming of Age in Second Life, Tom Boellstorff
conducted a study of user experiences in Second
Life, but critically did not involve the user’s
real lives or any other websites or software
in his analysis.
The work drew criticism from Alex Golub, who
identified this as a dramatic oversight.
The virtual worlds of MMOs are not enclosed
worlds.
[Choice] My experience with World of Warcraft
is not limited to the executable file on my
harddrive.
Discord, Twitch, Twitter, Google Docs, they
are all ‘places’ where I can engage with
World of Warcraft without ‘inhabiting’
World of Warcraft.
I work as a contributor to Skill Capped, an
analyst for BDGG and produce my own YouTube
content.
I might be at the point where I spend more
time doing WoW outside of WoW than I spend
inside it.
So we have MMO-Champion, WoWhead or whatever,
the term we will be using for this material
is “paratext”.
If you’re into a certain, lame, type of
youtube video, “paratext” is a word you’ll
have heard before.
It’s one of those words that gets thrown
around quite a bit, but is rarely given a
clean definition.
The concept of paratext was originally conceived
by French literary theorist Gérard Genette.
Genette saw a book as containing the text
of the book, the primary work, but also containing
other components that were necessary for the
book to be complete but that were not an element
of the primary text.
You have the actual story of Warcraft: Durotan,
but then you also have a cover, the title,
a foreword and so on.
Things that aren’t the ‘text’, but still
influence the meaning.
The title gives you some idea of what the
book is going to be about, the illustration
might tell you what a certain character looks
like.
For Genette, all of that additional text required
to make the work complete, was paratext.
But let’s be real, while this is all interesting,
it’s a bit of a niche.
It’s an acquired taste.
The field of literary academia focusing solely
on physical books is not a growth industry
in 2022.
There have been attempts to apply Genette’s
framework to the internet.
For instance, it could be said that this video’s
title and thumbnail represent paratext.
You saw the video recommended by YouTube and
formed some expectation based on what you
saw.
If you’ve encountered the term paratext
in the wild, it likely wasn’t Genette’s
definition, but rather the definition attributed
to Mia Consalvo.
Consalvo is a Comms professor who tastefully
and delicately but firmly expanded upon Genette’s
formulation.
[Dan] For Consalvo, paratext was any text
that “may alter the meanings of a text,
further enhance meanings, or provide challenges
to sedimented meanings.”
So paratext are texts that exist to influence
what we think of a separate, primary text.
This is reviews, walkthroughs, pre-release
trailers and so on.
The material that “surround, shape, support
and provide context for texts.”
There is a legitimate criticism to be made
that this ever broadening definition is quickly
becoming so vague as to lose all meaning.
But for our purposes, this is a blessing.
WoWhead and Warcraftlogs are paratext for
World of Warcraft.
Developer interviews are paratext.
Forum boards and twitter threads have been
called paratext.
Podcasts, fan art, and machinima straddle
the blurry line of being both texts and paratexts,
converting the original text into a paratext
that provides context and meaning to the derivatives.
AddOns have been called paratext.
Whatever this is, Paratext.
[Crusader] 2 v 3 biiiiiiitch!
Do do do do do do!
Trash players!
Traaaaaaaash!
In most media, a movie or painting is produced,
and then paratext is produced which can then
act on the dominant text, a particularly incisive
review can persuade you into a given reading
of the story and themes, or fan fiction can
emphasize the prominence of romantic tension
that would otherwise appear subtle or even
non-existent, that kind of thing.
Maybe if a movie gets a sequel, the filmmakers
will respond to what people liked or disliked
and thus the paratext has influence over subsequent
texts.
It is common for paratext to alter the way
that people talk about something, but for
the most part that’s where it stops; it
is very rare for paratext to go beyond that
and actually alter a text.
World of Warcraft, like many online games,
has a bit of a different relationship.
World of Warcraft is constantly being updated
and altered, there is no static final product
that can sit on shelves and be dusted off
by critics decades later, and since Wow is
constantly being updated so is a lot of the
talk about WoW.
The paratext is in a constant state of churn
in lock-step with the game.
At a basic level, paratext is a form of feedback
for the developers.
YouTube videos critical of certain changes,
bad reviews of an expansion launch in major
outlets, explosive forum threads or viral
Tweets, the developers and writers are in
an inevitable dialogue with these paratexts,
as subsequent updates to the game will inevitably
be read as either integration or rejection
of the vision presented by those outlets.
But beyond that, paratext interacts with social
practices.
Paratext emerge from, create and disseminate
social practices.
And what then tends to be prescribed are ideals
of instrumental play.
When a new strategy or idea is discussed,
people make guides or posts discussing it
and push it out in the world.
That then influences how the game is played
and what practices are considered correct
and legitimate.
The expressions of this can be surprisingly
pervasive in really unexpected places such
as which of two perfectly symmetrical hallways
is the correct path to take.
There is a shocking amount of social friction
that can be generated by looking at two identical
choices, and picking the one other players
weren’t expecting.
In The Sepulcher Of the First Ones these two
paths at the entrance are the same.
They’re literally identical.
There is absolutely nothing to distinguish
going left from going right.
But for whatever arbitrary reason, Looking
for Raid groups have established an entirely
unspoken assumption, a rut-like convention,
that you go to the right.
If you get dropped into a randomly assembled
LFR group and you lead the group down the
left path?
People will yell at you.
These are the foundation of all the small
rituals players engage in as they wordlessly
navigate a dungeon for the fiftieth time.
These are the rituals that allow players to
just know what their expected role is, why
they are the one expected to stand somewhere
or do something without anyone saying anything.
Many of these silent ruts are just that: ruts
of habit with no consequence, but the reactions
get even more intense if there are consequences,
even trivial ones, that can be mathematically
quantified in some way or another as less
efficient practice.
[Choice] In the Plaguefall dungeon, the first
boss, the delightfully named Globgorg, will
summon sets of slime creatures that will make
their way toward him.
If any reach Globgorg, he will be healed for
a portion of his health.
Low-difficulty or uncoordinated groups usually
just turn and kill the slimes.
But at the highest difficulties, the standard
practice is to focus damage on the boss and
prevent the larger slimes from reaching the
boss with ‘Crowd Control’.
If executed correctly, this positioning and
strategy trivializes the fight.
And it’s not difficult, but the risk is
enormous.
Any breakdown in the management of the slimes
can immediately brick an entire dungeon run.
Upon first discovering this strategy on a
Twitch stream, we became immediate evangelists
for the Globgorg Gambit.
We essentially became agents of the strategy,
and went on to spread its influence even further.
To quote Kristine Ask, “theorycrafting paratext
both spread and stabilize theorycrafted expertise,
co-producing a more performance-oriented playstyle.”
Put another way, when players theorycraft,
when they come up with strategies, when they
run math through spreadsheets to decide which
option is numerically superior, and these
strategies proliferate through the playerbase,
they don’t merely spread the specific strategies,
they also legitimize and elevate the act of
theorycrafting itself and push all players,
indirectly, towards a playstyle where optimization
is the correct mode of play.
World of Warcraft is so interesting because
it has lived through multiple generations
of the internet.
Because the game is so influenced by paratext,
changes in our capacity for paratext manifest
as changes in the game itself.
As the internet changes how we communicate,
the way we talk about WoW also changes, and
that fact changes WoW.
In the game's early life, Thotbott and later
WoWhead were, famously, major resources.
But they were only as good as the information
that users fed into them, and it took time
for the sites to build up a repository of
information.
And that didn’t guarantee accurate information,
just the existence of information.
However, as Mark Chen points out, that didn’t
stop the use of these sites from becoming
expert practice.
Actually the complete opposite happened.
[Dan] Rather than being seen as cheating,
using WoWhead was a thing that the best players
did.
And in 2006, it relied on word-of-mouth, you
had to be told about Thottbot to learn about
it.
In her book Cheating, Consalvo points out
how common it was for strategy guides or sites
like GameFAQs to be perceived as cheating,
as ‘illegitimate’ practices.
So it’s interesting how WoW would invert
that dynamic at a similar period of time.
And as Ask points out, that’s, uh, weird.
When World of Warcraft released, streaming
video was in its earliest stages and it has
existed through from that into the rise of
HD videos on YouTube through to 1440p livestreams
on Twitch.
Like, this is actually worth stressing, because
it plays into the way that information spread,
information asymmetry, has changed over the
course of the game.
If you were watching a strategy video in 2007,
it looked like this.
[Music]
But today, in the sci-fi future of the 2020s?
[Narrator] Now, when the fight starts you’re
going to want to spread and take positions
somewhat similar to this.
Now the reason you’re gonna want to be spread
out like this is because Archimonde has an
ability called Air Burst.
Now this does 1500 nature damage in a 15 yard
AoE around his target.
[Dan] In his 2013 thesis, Play to win, Benjamin
Egliston predicted the rise of twitch streams
as a primary source of knowledge for World
of Warcraft.
The printed strategy guides that Consalvo
wrote about already feel like a distant memory.
In 2022, it’s common for players to seek
out primary sources of knowledge in the form
of twitch streamers or relevant discord servers.
[cut to DK VoDs]
Someone looking how to play a Blood Death
Knight in keystones has access to livestreams
from dozens of excellent Blood DKs.
Potentially hundreds of hours of VoDs to comb
through.
Taken in its totality, the effect of all this
material can be somewhat insidious.
When discussing strategy guides, Consalvo
observed that these guides taught young players
that exploration, persistence and strategizing
were essential to succeed in their given game.
Essentially, the strategy guides taught its
readers what it meant to be an “ideal gamer”.
When Choice makes one of his dorky PvP guides
and pushes it out into the internet to wither
on the vine, it implicitly communicates that
instrumental values are desirable traits.
The video inadvertently reinforces the idea
that watching PvP guides is a good thing to
be doing.
Each video represents a brick in an echo chamber
that carries a subtle, yet deafening resonance.
The value ascribed to these videos turns the
game’s best players into the game’s biggest
celebrities.
This accelerates the process, as their expert
practices gain increasingly rapid adoption.
Kristine Ask first observed this phenomenon
over a decade ago.
Imagine having this ringing in your ears for
so long.
What would that do to a person?
[Choice] This robot is a product of paratext.
It’s an understatement to say that simulations
have been entrenched in World of Warcraft.
They are a core pillar of the game, and often
are the foundation on which other pillars
rest.
Best in Slot lists, gameplay guides, even
boss strategies themselves, are built off
principles that arise from simulations and
the values they carry.
When referring to the combat logging site,
Warcraft Logs, Egliston said “such applications
are now used casually, reinforcing competition
at all levels of play.”
“Through the production of paratexts, competitive
players are not only creating emergent tools
for cultivating tactics, but also repositioning
the skilled player as an influential force
in game design.”
This state of affairs has become so normalized
as to be seen as value neutral.
In the case of WoW because of the pace at
which paratext is incorporated into the game,
either explicitly as feedback or implicitly
as the dialect of design, the barrier between
WoW and its paratext has become so thin as
to be non-existent, and nowhere is that more
apparent than the subject of AddOns.
[Dan] AddOns are, of course, software that
can be run inside of another piece of software.
AddOns were a major pillar of PC gaming in
the late 90s and early 2000s and they remain
extremely relevant through to today.
Many famous titles began their life as mods,
many titles are socially considered unplayable
without modding, some legacy titles are literally
unplayable without them especially as hardware
and operating systems leave them behind, and
mods are a wonderful tool for budding game
devs to learn the craft by poking around and
fiddling with a completed project.
Mods are still around, but mod support is
far less pervasive than it was twenty years
ago.
Today, if a game has mod support it tends
to be a hugely influential aspect of the game.
Titles like Minecraft, Oxygen Not Included,
Cities: Skylines, and indeed World of Warcraft,
don’t see mod support as an extra little
feature, but a core element of their game’s
identity.
So while mods haven’t gone away, their scope
is far more limited.
In 2022 the biggest titles are online competitive
multiplayer games driven by live service monetisation.
Titles like Counter-Strike or League of Legends
place huge emphasis on their competitive and
esport elements.
These are games where the integrity of the
competition is critical.
Support for AddOns represent an unstable element
that few game developers get involved with.
In fact, most developers of esport-adjacent
titles have an extremely harsh view on any
third party software that interacts with the
competitive element of their game.
There are a few exceptions.
Team Fortress 2 gives the player the ability
to alter the game’s HUD.
The power the user is given to change the
UI is pretty dramatic, however they cannot
add new UI elements, only alter the presentation
of base elements.
The closest comparison I was able to find
to a WoW UI mod was, like, SimpleRadar for
Counter Strike.
This is a major point of departure for World
of Warcraft.
WoW wants to be counted amongst your League
of Legends and Valorants, and while WoW laid
a lot of groundwork for the modern live-service
model, WoW wasn’t built to be like those
games, it was built to be like Everquest and
Dark Age of Camelot.
Both games from the early 2000s with mod support.
Mods in that era were significantly less potent,
and the competitive, instrumental play of
2022 didn’t really exist in Everquest in
2003.
There is an old allakhazam tutorial on modding
in EQ from February 2003, it lists the following
hypothetical uses of mods.
“Mods can introduce new information or functions
into the EQ interface, make things easier
to use, or make the playing screen more pleasing
to the eye.
They can turn your cursor into a Nature Walker’s
Scimitar, put a dragon in your spellbook,
and put every important zone [location] or
tradeskill recipe only a mouseclick away while
you are in-game.”
These are not what we would today consider
gameplay altering mods.
They are aesthetic and ergonomic changes.
These are precisely the kinds of mods that
developers of the time would anticipate users
creating.
And the appeal of these mods are pretty clear.
Users are empowered to sculpt the game to
their own liking, and that remarkable feature
is almost entirely outsourced.
Mods offer huge value to companies, who are
the ultimate beneficiaries of the work of
passionate volunteers.
In 2003, the developers working on World of
Warcraft were not making a competitive title,
they were making an Elder Scrolls-Ultima-Everquest
type thing.
Of course, a few people would inevitably min-max
the systems, like any other DnD descendant.
But the decision to support mods wouldn’t
be one with decades of consequences.
Probably.
[Choice] World of Warcraft in a lot of ways
is a victim of its own success.
Its extensive mod support is a relic of a
bygone era.
Mods today are more powerful than the founders
could have imagined.
We can argue whether or not Blizzard should
have locked down their API more during development.
But ultimately that frames the debate as Blizzard
needing to ‘save us from ourselves’.
The decision to give mod developers freedom,
though perhaps naive, was rooted in player
and consumer empowerment, as mod support so
often is.
It’s what modders created and our eagerness
to embrace them that put us in this position.
So while this may seem redundant, we want
to take a second to draw a distinction between
AddOns and, well, AddOns.
On the one hand we have mods like OneBag,
Aurora, and MyRoleplay.
Mods that improve the user experience or offer
some new feature without influencing combat.
I would rope most of the Dragonflight UI customisation
options into this category.
On the other hand you have BigWigs and Gladius
whose whole purpose is to improve player performance
in combat.
These are mods whose creation and use is predicated
on instrumental and expert practices, which
is to say: these mods exist to provide information
that allows you to improve your performance.
Since these mods are used explicitly in the
pursuit of an advantage, a conversation about
cheating and legitimacy naturally follows.
Even though most players don’t frame this
conversation in academic terms, a lot of us
feel the subject of legitimacy hanging in
the air, like a nerdy poltergeist.
The mods we are most concerned with, the mods
with the greatest influence on combat, are
the ones that assume cognitive load.
[Dan] The seminal authority on this incredibly
niche concept is Mark Chen’s 2011 dissertation
Leet Noobs.
Chen wrote extensively about AddOns and their
influence on raid practices as early as 2006,
but his insights have only grown more relevant
over time as the influence of AddOns has grown.
In Leet Noobs, Mark Chen is concerned with
how raid groups become successful, and the
complex social and technical systems that
emerge in a coordinated raid environment.
Chen sought to demonstrate how AddOns could
become essential to a raid.
To begin, Chen develops on Edwin Hutchin’s
concept of distributed cognition.
For Hutchin, many cognitive tasks can be conceptualized
as activities that can be offloaded onto material
resources.
If I take notes on a sheet of paper, if I
jot down the passcode to a door or the location
of a hidden treasure, I am offloading the
cognitive tasks of memory onto the pen and
paper.
The pen and paper are assuming certain responsibilities,
they are not passive things, but are actively
performing a duty of carrying a cognitive
load on my behalf.
Chen takes this concept to its logical extreme
and asks whether it even matters whether an
actor in a given system is human or non-human.
This concept is called object-oriented ontology,
where everything exists equally, tools are
treated as though they have agency.
My brain and a pen and paper are equally capable
of accomplishing the task of remembering my
doctor’s appointment.
There are certainly critiques that can be
made of this framework.
In the context of notetaking, it could be
argued that the paper merely enhances my memory,
rather than assuming responsibility.
But as you will see, certain mods are so potent
at taking on responsibility, that ‘agency’
is probably the best way to describe it.
This leads Chen to a lengthy discussion of
actor-network theory.
ANT posits that the roles and responsibilities
within a ‘network of activity’, such as
an organization or a raid group, are distributed
across multiple actors.
And object-oriented ontology tells us that
those actors need not be human.
And since a raid group is nothing more than
a network of actors, Chen argues that AddOns
can become essential agents in a raid environment.
[Choice] So, the AddOns we are most concerned
with are the ones that take on some cognitive
load that would otherwise be placed on players,
individually or collectively.
From this we can place mods on a kind of abstract
spectrum of just how much cognitive load they
carry.
A lot of mods we just don’t care about,
such as those cosmetic or ergonomic mods,
because they carry no meaningful cognitive
load in combat.
On the other end of the spectrum mods like
Gladius, Diminish or OmniBar carry a very
high amount of cognitive load, because they
desperately want to contribute to combat.
The smallest example of a useful mod we can
think of, our minimum unit of cognitive load,
would be the crosshair.
It’s not uncommon now to see top end raiders
play with a WeakAura that marks the center
of their screen, representing where their
character is.
Your character cannot, typically, leave the
center of your screen.
So strictly speaking, the crosshair is entirely
redundant information.
It is an actor whose role is to answer a question
whose answer never changes.
Where is my character, it’s in the middle
of the screen, where it always is.
And yet if we show you footage of a modern
raid, you can see how the crosshair can decipher
the visual noise.
‘Where is my character?’ is a simple question
to answer, but having that certainty, not
having to take the extra split second to find
your dude in the chaos, that is valuable,
and that task can be offloaded to two brightly
coloured lines.
In recent years, competitive raid guilds have
made a big deal about the 21st raider, an
additional player outside of the raid that
coordinates players as the raid’s leader
via livestreams.
Traditionally that role was performed by a
player within the raid, but the demands of
the role have grown to the point now where
a player within the raid is not expected to
carry that amount of cognitive load.
The cognitive load of managing the raid has
been outsourced to an additional actor who
is not on the raid frames.
However, that idea is not remotely new.
T. L Taylor, writing in 2009 on the subject
of raiding in Molten Core, framed a predecessor
to DBM as “a kind of autonomous agent, the
41st member of the raid.”
It’s quite common for raid mods like DBM
or BigWigs to assign players to certain locations
or to perform certain duties.
On the Mythic Jailer encounter, six players
are marked as the bomb, they’re about to
explode.
To keep their friends alive, they each need
to jump in a unique hole.
To minimize the amount of coordination or
communication required, players offload the
problem to a mod.
An AddOn assigns each player their own hole,
and your duty as a raider is to do what the
robot tells you.
By the time this goes live, progression for
Vault of the Incarnates will begin in less
than a fortnight.
A huge point of discussion for us has been
how to best utilize mods to assume as much
responsibility as possible.
Just how much of our Raid Leader could be
replaced with MS Susan?
[Dan] In Leet Noobs, Chen discusses at great
length how the creation of threat meters affected
his guild.
We take it for granted today, but in early
WoW the threat system was a black box.
The lack of knowledge around threat meant
that players couldn’t necessarily ‘optimize’
their damage, because if they did too much
damage they would simply pull aggro and die.
And you couldn’t put a number to what ‘too
much damage’ even was.
Chen describes in detail his guild’s theories
on how threat functioned.
I won’t get into the details, but it was
a vision of threat that had rogues afraid
to ever press Eviscerate, a core ability that
famously was kind of important, it was worth
a press.
“Eviscerate does static damage!”
Early theories on threat were similar to Onyxia’s
famous deep breath, it was shrouded in half-truths,
vague uncertainties and a healthy dose of
superstition.
Threat in 2004 was what we’d today call
a vibe, you felt it out.
A scenario like this, where DPS are deliberately
holding back their damage due to concerns
about threat, significantly increased the
difficulty of bosses.
The superstition was replaced with absolute
knowledge.
“A mechanic that was previously invisible
but still present was made visible in order
to be made useful.”
The process of threat was now a process of
real-time data analysis.
If the rogue saw that they had a decent buffer
on threat, they could press Eviscerate where
they would have once hesitated.
As tools, the damage meter naturally preceded
the threat meter.
But in the early days the value of damage
meters wasn’t appreciated.
Chen observed that his guild members initially
struggled to see the purpose or value in these
tools.
He invoked the metaphor of ‘trying to describe
a bicycle to a fish’.
But once they were adopted, they quickly became
essential to Chen’s guild, and the threat
meter naturally elevates the damage meter.
Because ultimately, the value of threat management
is measured in damage per second.
The creation of the damage meter created the
conditions that allowed players to optimize
their damage output, and thus legitimized
the damage meter as a meaningful signifier
of contribution.
The reason why we articulate the value of
gear in terms of damage per second, is because
DPS is the base unit that we use to measure
value to a raid.
What was once the central pillar of the DPS
experience was completely changed almost overnight.
In the years that followed, threat became
a rudderless system, ignored by players unless
they chafed against it.
Over the years Blizzard has had a few cracks
at making it relevant again; but as you’ll
recall, the creators can’t force it.
In a modern context it is easy to view this
as a positive thing - threat sucks and the
game is better off without it sitting on top
of everything.
That may be true, but because nothing with
WoW is simple, there is more to it than that.
Chen describes a couple of different players
from the early days, each with various quirks,
but for narrative simplicity we’re going
to merge them into the archetype of Wallace,
a character who walks between encounters and
doesn’t wear shoes - two real behaviors
that Chen witnessed.
“There was one of my guild mates, not guild
mates because we were in a different guild,
raid mates - since he was in a different guild.
He played this character who refused to wear
boots, or footwear.
Every piece of clothing or item you get can
add to your stats.
So to not wear boots is a handicap, but like,
we didn’t care because he was roleplaying
and having fun and stuff … And there was
another person who never ran.
Which is a total pain in the ass, because
you have to wait for this person to take forever
to get to wherever you're going, but he never
ever ran in the game.”
The experience of the Wallaces of the world
was to rapidly see the attitude of the world
shift around them, from light roasting over
silly character decisions to active hostility.
Threat meters changed what raiding meant.
To RP walk everywhere wasn’t a cute character
trait, it was leaving the job of trash clearing
to everyone else.
Wallace’s lesser contribution could be portrayed
with the objectivity of mathematics.
This is how social practices change, and how
mods can drive that change.
Threat meters and damage meters created a
new framework for which WoW could be viewed
by players, and as an individual, you could
either accept that change or leave.
Wallace not wearing shoes shifted from being
an self-imposed limitation with very nebulous
consequences to being a very precisely quantifiable
measure of exactly just how much Wallace was
failing to Play Correctly.
And in defining what it meant to ‘correctly’
play World of Warcraft, we narrowed down the
legitimate means of inhabiting Azeroth.
In doing so, the infinite world that so enthralled
those anthropologists grew just that little
bit smaller.
A typical single player game may be built
with instrumental play in mind, it may even
distinctly cater to it, but peak instrumental
practices can often be quarantined from mainstream
view.
Think speed running.
I love Dark Souls 3, but have never seriously
looked at speed running it.
In comparison to regular play, the speed runs
look incoherent, the two are disconnected
to the point they’re functionally different
games.
A rich speed running scene can exist without
it influencing my experience of the game.
[WoW footage]
World of Warcraft, in contrast, has a very
different relationship with instrumental practices.
You can’t really escape them, even if you
try.
Even the social elements of the game, things
seemingly free of numbers, become vessels
for the propagation of the numbers.
WoW is a big game, and it’s extremely complex
and is composed of nearly two decades of sediment,
long strings of stuff positioned with little
baked in explanation of what it’s for, why
it’s there, or even if you should bother.
When new content is introduced no one goes
back to the old stuff to drop signs saying
“hey, this place is kinda done, you sure
you want to be here?”
There’s a lot of reasons for that, namely
it wouldn’t even necessarily make the game
better, but it’s a thing, and as a result
it creates a lot of cul-de-sacs.
If you stumble into the Molten Front in 2022
it’s kinda left to you to figure it out,
the game’s not going to tell you that this
content stopped being relevant November 29,
2011.
So, given the existence of these cul-de-sacs,
what is always the first piece of advice given
to new players?
Join a guild, find people who will help answer
questions and offer guidance, people who are
up-to-date on the game, who can collectively
remember what things are, and point you at
what you can or should be doing, who can tell
you that the Molten Front is not only a cul-de-sac
but also kinda lame and there’s not a lot
of reason to be there.
Whether it be that kind of spontaneous, organic
help, or the systematized information from
Elitist Jerks, guilds are repositories of
knowledge.
Kristine Ask describes guilds as communities
of practice, as institutions that store information.
They are communities defined in part by what
they do and why they do it.
From the very start, players are primed to
engage with WoW as a process of adopting certain
practices.
World of Warcraft is a game with a large degree
of interdependence, and interdependence is
always a tricky mix of reliance and imposition.
In order for you to accomplish your goals,
you may require me to perform a certain task
to a certain level of proficiency.
And if I can’t do that, well, odds are no
one’s going to be happy with what happens
next.
[Minus fifty DKP]
WoW’s raiding environment pushes this to
its most extreme.
As you’ll recall, Chen describes a raid
as a network of actors.
Like a musical band, sports team or school
project.
As a scheduled, regular social obligation,
it’s fair to say some degree of ‘success’
is required to keep players motivated to attend,
no one wants to feel stuck or left behind.
As discussed earlier, it can be said that
success in WoW is socially defined, what it
means to be “stuck” depends on where everyone
else is.
The raid groups that perform the most effectively
tend to do so by treating raiding essentially
like work, their work defines what success
looks like in the game, and in turn their
practices become the expert practices as anyone
who doesn’t want to feel stuck adopts their
strategies, their group compositions, their
add-ons, and their organization, because there
might be a bunch of different strategies that
do work, but we know theirs does work, and
if it works it must work for a reason.
[Choice] For instance, Limit achieved the
World First kill of N’Zoth by using an external
raid leader.
That 21st player outside the raid we mentioned
earlier.
This was not unheard of, but it was not a
common practice until Limit’s success.
Three years later, it’s a ubiquitous tactic
in the World First Race.
And our friends over at Venture, the trinket
guys, they love the external raid leader.
From Twitch streams to full strategy guides,
guilds like Limit create paratext that document
their practices.
This paratext not only contains the methodology
to overcome a specific boss fight or fix a
certain problem, but you’ll recall it also
normalizes itself as a legitimate framework
to apply to raiding.
This is a byproduct of emergent play, the
game’s best players have gotten very good
at finding unintended solutions to the challenges
put in front of them.
Which means that what they end up doing can
often be in conflict with what the intuitive
solution would appear to be.
What the designers may well have intended
the solution to be.
Over the course of years, theorycrafting has
become so entrenched in the minds of even
casual players, that it appears value neutral.
The way we conceptualize a raid encounter,
the terminology we use, the way we judge success,
it is all informed from behaviors disseminated
from the top down.
Even when we do see innovation emerge from
relative unknowns, like Restricted’s awesome
Mythic Jailer strategy, those strategies are
still products of instrumental practices.
This goes beyond stabilization of theorycrafting
as an abstract value, this is extremely tangible.
If a critical mass of guilds are replicating
the best guilds, then the behaviors of those
top guilds have a direct impact on the whole
culture.
This level of instrumental play creates a
player base that is better and more coordinated
than they otherwise would be.
Blizzard can either ignore this and create
content that is trivialized by AddOns, or
they can presume that they will be used.
This has gradually resulted in content that
presumes the existence of these tools, and
thus pushes players towards adopting them.
We have seen this phenomenon play out quite
rapidly in the game’s competitive PvP.
Mods that were once prohibited from tournament
play have become permissible and their rate
of adoption has skyrocketed.
This had tremendous implications for the game’s
balance.
The best players, who had a culture of minimizing
AddOn-usage due to tournaments being seen
as the legitimate measure of success, suddenly
picked mods up and started outperforming all
expectations.
Crucially, this legitimized mod usage in a
PvP community more broadly, giving players
permission to go crazy.
This resulted in players who could react faster
than before and make decisions with a certainty
they never previously possessed.
The game designers sought to offset these
consequences, and the game now demands an
airhorn whenever a monk casts Bonedust Brew.
The only solution to the impact of mods is
to rely more on those same mods.
It’s a feedback loop.
As the Race to World First has continued to
pursue professionalism, we’ve seen AddOns
become a crucial element of the process.
For years now, the contending guilds have
had honest-to-God software developers on their
rosters to develop specialized software to
assist in encounters.
“WeakAuras” is a mod that is so powerful
that it’s not accurate to even call it a
mod.
It is one part software development language,
one part mod distribution platform.
It would be easier to list the things that
WeakAuras cannot do.
It can be used to single-handedly rebuild
an entire UI, it could be the only mod you
ever use.
But even that is underselling this thing.
I would lose my job if I accurately described
what we can do with WeakAuras.
WeakAuras have become the first port of call
for any problem in high end raiding.
Applying the principles of cognitive distribution,
the first question in response to any problem
is ‘can a WeakAura handle that?’
To which the answer is most often, yes!
It is increasingly common to see mods form
the spine of strategies for these top guilds.
Many encounters, such as Mythic Fatescribe
have strategies that rely on WeakAuras to
effectively execute.
Since deferring to WeakAuras is the first
choice, it is extremely rare for an alternate
solution to emerge.
What is there to gain by digging your heels
in and not using the assignment WeakAura for
Jailer Runes?
Since no other alternate solutions exist,
these WeakAuras become fundamental tools that
are adopted basically universally.
The same tools designed by and for professional
raiders end up as standard practice.
A popular observation regarding AddOns is
the way in which they enable or encourage
surveillance among players.
A mod like CT_RaidAssist would function if
other players weren’t using it, but its
effectiveness was predicated on mass adoption.
In the case of these auras, they require everyone
in the raid to use them in order for them
to function correctly.
If you join a raid and don’t have the correct
pack installed, all the little elves that
tell everyone where to stand during Prototype
Pantheon melt down.
This has led to the creation of WeakAuras
to ensure you have the right WeakAuras.
Sepulcher of the First Ones was dominated
by this bullshit.
[Dan] So to recap, strategies seep from the
top down, the strategies that the best guilds
use inform the techniques that will see mass
adoption.
Smart practice for these guilds is to offload
responsibilities onto AddOns wherever possible,
this results in a critical mass of strategies
that build themselves around these tools.
Since there is rarely incentive to develop
an alternative practice, tactics grounded
in these mods see near total adoption.
These tools rely on all players running the
software individually, so players have next
to no say in whether they install this software.
Because this practice is so widely adopted,
Blizzard, quite rightly, develops fights presuming
these tools will exist, further entrenching
them as mandatory and incentivizing guilds
to run even more tools to surveil raid members
and enforce compliance.
And this is how a guild like mine ends up
mirroring the practices of professionals.
We aren’t pursuing high ranks or looking
to flatter our egos, we just want to enjoy
ourselves.
We just want a sense of forward momentum week
to week.
In Shadowlands, we’ve found ourselves pressing
people to do things they wouldn’t otherwise
do, whether that’s run keys, install mods,
switch specs, or hell, switch classes.
It parallels the experiences of Kristine Ask,
who writes that her 2009 guild, “The Gummy
Wolves”, sought to tempter their instrumental
practices.
They wanted to do well on their own terms,
without just doing what Elitist Jerks did.
They mocked the “no lifers” who took the
game too seriously, but yet were continually
lured toward adopting the ideas and practices
and strategies offered up by Elitist Jerks
because, well, they work.
Because that’s the thing about these practices,
they aren’t arbitrary, they exist because
they solve these problems.
And if adopting some of these techniques is
what gets your raid group from stalling out
to comfortably succeeding, that is a trade
that some would be happy to take.
But for those players who are left behind,
clearly the problem is the game itself.
The coevolution of WoW hit a dead end, if
you catch my drift.
This arms race between the devs and the players,
it’s gotten out of hand.
What we need to do is hit the reset button,
abandon all this nonsense and return to a
simpler time.
Surely, surely, that will fix this.
[Music]
When I first covered WoW Classic, I painted
a picture of a game whose primary appeal was
tourism, a chance to revisit a compelling
game but ultimately one without lasting appeal
to a broad playerbase.
I’ve received the odd request for a follow
up video every so often, and now seems like
as good a time as any to indulge.
In the recent marketing for WoW Classic, Blizzard
has lent in hard on appealing to the nostalgia
of a mainstream audience.
The advertisement is aimed first and foremost
at drawing back players who fell out of love
with the game.
I don’t know, maybe I was onto something.
However, this is not how a hardcore audience
conceives of Classic.
[Choice] Classic is a return to when the game
was more pure.
For example, a big complaint from the Classic
WoW purists are the difficulty modes that
WoW introduced to dungeon and raid content,
uh, in the first year of the Obama administration.
Raids should be meritorious.
Killing all the bosses in a raid should be
an achievement, and players should be sorted
from one another.
Not everyone should be able to finish the
raid.
As an example, let's use Battle of Dazar’alor
from 2019, the same year Classic WoW released.
This was widely regarded as an excellent raid
and may be among the best of the modern era.
Here we can see the distribution of progression
for the hardest difficulty.
This is where every guild who killed a boss
finished up.
For instance, Dan’s guild killed the first
two bosses on Mythic and so they’re somewhere
in this column.
As you can see, the largest portion of guilds
never killed the second boss.
Twice as many as actually finished the raid.
The data tells us a story of the raid, you
can see just how tough the 4th boss was relative
to the first three by how many people never
made it past it.
The distribution drops hard after the first
3 bosses.
This distribution resembles an ideal raid;
sure, Dan and his 2-decade old friend group
can see some bosses, but at a certain point
it's time for the men to take over.
This graph isn’t perfect, a Kungen-type
would probably tell you that too many people
are clearing the raid.
But it could be worse, compare this to the
Normal mode distribution of the raid.
Normal mode represents everything that the
classic purists hate about the modern game.
It’s a version of the raid intended for
any group to be able to finish with the bare
minimum of organization.
We can see from the data that the vast majority
of guilds who entered normal mode finished
it.
This number is pathetic, it fails to distribute
players at all.
No matter your skill level you can expect
to clear normal mode.
A distribution like this, in the context of
instrumental play, is terrifying.
What does an objective-driven playstyle look
like when the explicit objectives of the game
can’t provide an appropriate goal?
Sure, some portion of this stack are well-serviced
by this raid, but some unknown number would
be disengaged by this because it’s just
too easy.
What would the game turn into for those players
if they didn’t have difficulty-appropriate
content?
A distribution like this is deeply unhealthy
for the game.
And it’s the reason why WoW’s early raids
were so difficul-
I mean, that’s fucking Molten Core man,
it’s the first raid they ever made, of course
it’s going to be eas-
Uh, Dan, tag in.
[Dan] A lot of ink has been spilled on why
Classic hasn’t delivered on the difficulty
promised by those early evangelists.
We won't relitigate that in too much detail
here.
In short, players are better, their internet
is better and for practical reasons the game
runs on the final build of the expansion,
so player characters end up being stronger
than they ought to be.
But the big one is the presence of paratext.
It’s not just that the content is 12 years
old, and everything has been solved, it’s
that the solution has been widely disseminated
and widely adopted.
Like, here’s a taste of a 3-hour lecture
on changes to Shaman going from Vanilla to
the Burning Crusade.
Please, I insist.
“The testings of spell coefficients and
weapon imbues I present here were done using
a 2.4.3 TBC repack which is not an official
Blizzard product.
Despite this almost all spell coefficients
and weapon imbue results corroborate what
has been tested by multiple TBC-era theorycrafters.
However, until an official pre-patch, beta,
and/or live TBC game has been released, I
cannot be 100% sure the spell coefficients
and weapon imbue results are completely correct.”
Yeah, we were always going to demolish Classic,
it was always going to go this way.
This is not to say that a Sunwell or Ulduar
raid is an unenjoyable experience for modern
players familiar with the game, just that
it is not strictly a challenging one.
The issue Classic faces is that the vast majority
of players are exhausting the content at an
absurd pace, most within the first week or
two.
These are people who love the game dearly,
and are magnitudes better than the creators
could have imagined.
What are they supposed to do to fill the time?
The same thing as anyone else who has a deep
love of a single game, they started speed
running.
Speed running has been an element of WoW for
basically the game’s entire life.
But before Classic WoW released, private servers
took it to a whole other level, these servers
would spin up and shut down so rapidly, that
players developed techniques for speed running
the entire game.
Those players and their imitators applied
their techniques to Classic WoW at launch,
Molten Core was cleared in just 6 days, down
from 154 days back in 2005.
This was a big story in the Classic circles,
but it didn’t really affect the tourists
in a meaningful way at launch.
Over the life of Classic, more and more players
found themselves adopting more and more of
these speedrun techniques.
Maybe it was an organic process, people just
looking to make their raids easier and find
a way to make them more engaging.
But I would suggest that instrumental play
compels players to try and organize themselves
by hierarchy.
Remember, the elitist players who want to
gatekeep content, they’re in here somewhere.
So they are naturally going to elevate means
of separating themselves from the pack.
So speed runs practices became expert practices,
and, well, over the course of years, that
cooks your brain.
Classic ought to have been our salvation from
all this, after all, the content doesn’t
demand the kind of optimization we’ve been
discussing, not by a long shot.
Classic should rightly be the playground of
the super-casual, a sandbox for players who
aren’t in any particular hurry to be anywhere.
And yet, it's gone the other way, Wrath of
the Lich King Classic has become a nightmare
of instrumental practices.
Yes, it’s not difficult, but the difficulty
isn’t the appeal, instead it’s about going
through this process perfectly.
To be good at Classic is to learn and adopt
the right practices.
To play the right class as the right race,
with the best professions; to level the quickest,
get server first, get the Shadowmourne you
never got.
In some cases, it seems really weird.
It’s like reliving high school.
You’re going to pick better electives, be
cooler, bet on the Cubs in 2016, and smash
when you've got the chance.
At the launch of Classic, these practices
existed, but they were largely invisible.
By definition, it did not mean anything to
you that some guys were in Molten Core while
you were in Wailing Caverns.
Whatever.
But after you quit Classic at level 47, these
players stuck around.
And these players established the practices
of what it meant to play Classic.
This process of riding the curve to the greatest
extent possible, it’s not the exception,
it’s the rule.
Again, look at these distributions.
No child is being left behind here, if you’re
entering the raid, you’re finishing it.
Returning to Wrath Classic in late 2022, there
is a palpable feeling that you’ve walked
into their space.
A walk around Dalaran showcases this, every
Death Knight and their ghoul is decked out
in the best gear, the most prestigious vanity
items, every player looks like the protagonist.
Things that were once status symbols are mundane.
The best gear is not a symbol of exceptionalism,
it’s a symbol of parity.
Having less than the best makes you less than
everyone else.
Because if you aren’t here, where else can
you be?
This was made crystal clear during the launch
of Wrath Classic, when players put absurd
gear requirements on groups for Utgarde Keep.
If you wanted to experience Utgarde Keep,
the famously easy introductory dungeon, on
the first day of Wrath, a majority of groups
expected you to have the best gear possible
Choice thought it was just his sweaty server,
but no, YouTuber AzAMOuS parodied this phenomenon
and the comment section is full of accounts
of similar experiences.
“Madorc you are noy good geared enough for
this dungeon.
Wot?
Is he joking?”
Like our trinket from earlier, it wasn’t
actually about efficiency.
There is a limit on how many times you can
do a dungeon within a given time.
It was not about efficiency, it was about
reinforcing the ingroup and excluding the
outgroup.
The instrumental practices of Classic are
no longer invisible, they’re in-your-face,
they’re the status quo.
[Choice] It is no doubt possible for a casual
guild of 40-somethings to have fun on Classic,
but like Kristine Ask’s guild back in 2009,
these practices are endemic to Classic.
There is no ivory tower for the best players
to escape to, you all want to do Naxxramas
this week.
I would argue that casual players feel more
out of place on Classic, because they disrupt
an otherwise seamless flow of knowledgeable
and overpowered players blowing through trivial
content.
You are their Wallace, bumbling into their
Normal Utgarde Keep.
This is the dissonance of the marketing of
Classic.
Blizzard wants Classic to be inviting to returning
players, a chance to return to a humble era.
Of course this is bullshit, Wrath was the
expansion that gave us GearScore, which if
you want to talk about mods influencing social
practices, there’s a doozy for you.
The social experience of Classic is immensely
frustrating and incredibly fucking stressful.
Once you step beyond the leveling experience,
every dungeon or raid is a ritual of actions
that has been accepted as standard and performed
without introduction.
It’s disorientating to have ancient dungeons
being done with private server routes.
Stuff you were meant to learn 7 years ago
from a Russian Hunter on Warmane’s 7x experience
BlizzLike pre-nerf Wrath server.
There is a tangible sense that you are always
behind the curve, always missing something.
I was so excited for Classic TBC, before I
learned that a bunch of gear from vanilla
content was on the Best-in-Slot list, like
the Mark of the Champion that was used all
the way into Sunwell.
It wasn’t that I needed it to kill Brutallus,
but it was the knowledge that I was already
behind.
Classic pushes you into one of two archetypes,
either buy in and end up here, or you reject
all this, and embrace the identity of a tourist.
The hardcore players congregate on the same
handful of servers, the casual players find
their servers starting to die and eventually
either need to transfer to those same super
realms, or endure their degrading server until
it eventually becomes unplayable and the player
drops the game altogether.
In other words, it’s just like fucking Retail.
Despite the promise of a journey to a better
yesterday, we ultimately recreated the same
environment as the main game.
Only there is no border to delineate between
the intensity of content.
For example, BDGG are a pseudo-professional
guild, our raiders are paid, in dollars, to
play WoW and perform their best in the raid
content, they have a lot of expectations to
meet and our analyst team has been hard at
work discussing what needs to be done in preparation
for this upcoming event.
One conversation that has not come up at all
is the leveling process.
Blizzard has had years to separate leveling
from the hardcore elements of the game.
Our raiders need to get a certain number of
characters to make level in the first week,
and some are genuinely going to blitz it,
because it’s in their nature.
But for our purposes, there is no need to
prescribe a method to them or push them to
get it done quickly.
They are allowed to take their time, react
to the cinematics with their viewers, explore,
goof off, whatever.
Many will experience the leveling of Dragonflight
entirely organically, like you would, or as
I will.
By contrast, check out this selection of the
guides on speed running to max level in Classic,
there is a whole industry built on selling
you instrumental practices.
The funniest thing I saw in Classic were these
guys who called themselves Team Supreme.
So, for context here, I joined a kind of middling
guild on a middling PvE server for Classic,
and I really, I wanted to sort of strike that
balance between hardcore and casual play.
I wanted to do well and sort of skip the failure
portion, but not have to go too hard.
And within this guild were these guys, Team
Supreme, and they were set on being the first
people on the server to get to level 70 in
the Burning Crusade.
So I approach them out of sincere curiosity
and ask them “hey, you know, what’s the
plan?”
And they tell me that they want to do 60 to
70 in twenty hours.
And that’s a… that’s a complicated number
to have picked, twenty hours.
If you’re a professional speedrunner, if
you’re Joker, and that is his name, his
name’s Joker, if you’re Joker and you
do this for a living, twenty hours is a pretty
doable number.
But I picked these guys because they were
a middling guild, I picked them because I
didn’t want them to have heard of Joker.
So to see so much energy being funneled into
these five guys to do this one activity, and
to hear twenty hours out of them, I knew they’d
made a mistake somewhere.
To be honest.
Not to be rude, but to hear twenty hours out
of these guys, okay, a mistake’s been made.
I became obsessed with this because in a way
it was like “I’m I the one out of touch,
have these guys pushed this further than I
could possibly ever have imagined, or have
they made this crucial mistake.”
Seeing all this work juxtaposed with what
I thought was just an ungodly number I had
to know what was going on.
So I ask them “hey, have you been on the
beta, have you tested this strategy?”
To which, to my astonishment, they said yes.
They log onto the beta, turn in all the pre-quests,
that process takes a full hour and nets them
one and a half levels.
Which is, that’s a really good outcome,
that is solid stuff.
And so at the end of the first hour they’re
doing well, looking really good.
They then proceed to run dungeons for the
next nine hours straight, so by the tenth
hour they are at level 65.
The half-way mark.
At which point they’re not going to do the
full 20 hours of dry run on the beta, so they
log off.
Because it logically follows having just done
60 to 65 in ten hours, ten more hours of dungeon
running will get them to level 70.
Fuck.
At times like this, people show you their
true colors.
I could have stopped them, I had multiple
opportunities to stop them, but I wanted it
to see this train reach its destination.
I was revealed to be an asshole.
But them?
They streamed the whole thing, and when the
penny finally dropped, they stuck together.
They were deeply miserable, but they didn’t
point fingers and they didn’t yell, instead
they pushed through it, they didn’t sleep;
20 hours became 37.
But they got what they wanted - they were
the first group on the server to hit max level,
they even finished two raids before anyone
else.
They won.
They had months to pick up on their mistake,
what business did Team Supreme have trying
to replicate the practices of speedrunners?
Well, because the internet told them to.
What else were they going to do?
As players, the push for Classic was in the
name of recapturing an essence of the game
that was lost, and Blizzard played their part
- they gave us the executable file.
But it ultimately failed, because we brought
the bug back with us.
We brought back the paratext industry that
sells solutions, we brought back the practices
that trivialized content, and when we had
nothing to do, we made a leaderboard out of
our day to day experiences.
Shout out to Rooster Juice and their 9:57
Heroic Nexus time.
What a legend.
[Dan] This discussion has been dominated by
sociology and anthropology.
We have talked to death about WoW as a series
of behaviors and trends.
But no one who came to WoW in its early years
was drawn to it by the promise of adopting
a series of social practices.
The genre of virtual worlds are defined first
and first foremost by just that - the world.
We can see that in how Azeroth is regarded.
It is considered the main character of WoW.
Sure, we can make fun of the many self-inserts
and over-played characters, but at the root
it is the World of Warcraft.
[Metzen quote from LFG - just says Azeroth
is the main character]
For many players in 2005, possibly even most
players, the persistence of Azeroth and all
that came with it, the day/night cycles, the
weather, the scheduled events, the ability
to walk in one direction for two straight
hours and experience not a parade of procedurally
generated noise, but hand-crafted vistas,
we had experienced nothing like it.
The world of Azeroth is beautiful.
The raid experience is a different story.
Raids in World of Warcraft can be severely
taxing on hardware, especially for weaker
machines.
This was keenly true in the game’s early
years when hardware was both less powerful
and raid groups involved significantly more
players.
It was often necessary to lower graphical
settings to improve hardware performance just
to make the game playable.
Or if you were Choice, and 13, be completely
oblivious to that and raid at 2 frames per
second.
Incredible.
Obviously, Choice’s performance was hindered
by his single digit framerate.
Altering your graphical settings would improve
the game performance and result in better
game performance, a better experience, a more
playable game.
This line of thinking opens the doors to manipulating
the graphical settings for efficient play.
[Choice] A simple example would be something
like this.
This quest involves collecting bottles that
are obscured amongst the grass.
You can either search the grass carefully
for the tiny little bastard bottles, or you
can open up the graphical settings, pull the
ground clutter slider to 1 and remove almost
all the grass in the environment, revealing
the bottles completely unobstructed.
Expert practice is to manipulate the world
to the greatest extent possible in the service
of instrumental play.
The Potion of Inky Blackness is a cosmetic
item that shifts the player’s perception
of the world from day to night.
It has no overt value, but when used in specific
environments, it increases the contrast on
certain visual effects, making them easier
to see.
In Sepulcher of the First Ones, the potion
saw usage on 5 of the 11 bosses.
The potion heavily alters the color palette
of the environment; it doesn’t necessarily
look bad, but it’s a bit shonky, and certainly
not the environmental artists’ intended
for the space.
A long-standing practice has involved using
console commands to increase the follow distance
of the ingame camera to its maximum extent.
At its most extreme, it was zoomed further
back than the isometric camera of Warcraft
3, the player character reduced to a barely-identifiable
speck.
This God’s eye view, like in an RTS, allows
us to take in more of the play space.
In 2016, Blizzard tried to reign this in and
drastically limit the maximum camera distance.
As we have come to expect the players took
this in stride, adjusted their behaviour in
response, and remained above all respectful
in their dealings with their fellow man.
Just kidding, it was a shitshow, obviously.
It was among the biggest controversies of
its kind.
Blizzard, completely blindsided, eventually
backed down and only made a smaller adjustment.
They limited the camera enough to annoy players
who had become accustomed to viewing the game
like a World War 2 bomber pilot, but not enough
to fundamentally change the look of the game.
It remains a contentious topic to this day.
Blizzard’s argument for a reduced camera
was based on the nature of WoW as an RPG.
They argued that players ought to feel attached
to their character, and feel like they are
within the world.
The difference between this, and this.
[Dan] It has been observed for a long time
now that expert practice is to disable the
diegetic sound, but particularly the game’s
music.
Raids rely on coordination, which is often
done over voice chat software.
To make sure communication is clear, players
often turn the game’s sound way down, if
not off altogether.
The ‘auralscape’ of the environment is
removed, before the instrumental player rebuilds
it.
Voice communication is one element, and then
the alerts of AddOns serve as another.
The game already features audio cues for critical
events, cues lovingly crafted by designers
trying to build a cohesive, subtle, thematic
experience.
But if you need to make snap decisions, maybe
play it safe and replace Combustion with the
wilhelm scream.
In the absolute top Mythic Keystones, the
combat is so busy that all possible senses
are used to the fullest possible extent.
[Cacophony of audio alerts]
That cacophony, that’s the soundtrack of
keystones.
That’s the music of victory.
[Gunshot noises]
What’s really important to note is that
the music of victory isn’t the music of
the game itself.
It’s almost perverse the degree to which
the soundtrack, an entire pillar of the creative
product, has been functionally erased from
the game for the median player, having been
shut off in 2007 and never restored.
All of this is about tearing down the original
soundscape of World of Warcraft and repurposing
it as a means of success.
Josh Keaton’s performance as Anduin Wyrnn
is muted so you can better hear a 29 year
old software engineer from Montana coordinate
the most efficient movement between lanes
of zombies.
[Raid leader] Everyone needs to hard focus
the Monstrous Soul because we don’t have
lust, so..
[Choice] And with all of this established,
we can finally say the quiet part out loud.
Players make World of Warcraft look fucking
ugly.
Instrumental play values clarity, but only
‘clarity’ in regard to information.
It’s easy for this conversation to get caught
in the quagmire of ‘personal preferences’.
But these interfaces are not the product of
pure creative expression, they are the product
of instrumental practices.
So let’s go straight for the jugular and
highlight Mythic Archimonde as an example
of what we’re talking about.
Wrought Chaos was a pretty nuanced ability
but to be brief, players needed to be aware
of these arrows that telegraphed an upcoming
attack.
Clarity of the environment was incentivised.
You can see that in how Limit positions themselves
in this footage, it provides a clarity to
what is going on, even through a kind of busy
UI.
There was another solution though, and it
looked like this.
Players used a WeakAura that would attempt
to represent the trajectory of the beams as
2 dimensional vectors.
It’s pretty accurate, but not really.
As a means of trivializing the mechanic, it
is highly effective.
It is also objectively awful to look at.
There’s no personal preference argument
here, these vectors are entirely function.
The Hellfire Citadel Archimonde encounter
was already a kind of unpleasant fight visually,
but players pushed it completely over the
edge.
Mythic Archimonde is a sincerely ugly fight
to look back on, because it will forever be
through this lens, this mess.
Alex Golub called this the process of ‘decomposing
the world.’
And we’ve made an art form of it.
In context, Golub is using the term ‘decomposing’
as the inverse of composing, a dismantling
of the world.
But the imagery of decomposing, of decay,
that does feel appropriate.
There is no conspiracy, no central authority,
no plan, and yet we are uncompromising and
unrelenting.
For almost twenty years, Azeroth has been
rotting through instrumental play and it all
seems just… natural.
[Dan] And if we could roll the credits there,
that would be a great ending.
If only it were that simple.
The relationship between instrumental play
and fun is messy.
We are far from the first to observe these
issues, they aren’t exactly hard to see.
A common solution put forward is to heavily
wind back, if not outright remove, the game’s
AddOn support.
Despite everything, that’s not a solution
we’re super crazy about.
Mods offer unparalleled value to the consumer.
There is a reason they were, and remain, so
beloved by PC gamers.
Mod support is not solely this engine of chaos
that we’ve depicted it as, it is a means
of empowering users.
For that reason, the application of mods spans
far beyond what you’d expect.
The Tournament of Ages, the charity roleplay
festival from earlier, is built off the back
of AddOns.
Disability is an enormous subject that is
so important that we weren’t sure how best
to handle it.
For what it’s worth, Choice doesn’t like
to make a big deal about it, but his eyes
are cooked.
He is very much reliant on AddOns to play
his best, and so that will always short circuit
this type of conversation.
Mods offer means of accessibility that are
both broad and granular, custom to every individual’s
need, to a degree developers can never practically
match.
MDT, an incredibly complex mod that allows
players to plan and share routes through dungeons,
has dramatically altered the way that dungeons
are designed, by equipping players with the
tools and language to communicate complex,
interesting, strategies.
Arguably this whole process of negotiation,
the arms race between players and designers,
has resulted in more replayable, engaging,
fun content.
Mods are ultimately an expression of our own
behaviors.
Instrumental play, the act of attempting to
solve a game, ironically can’t be solved.
It’s not a puzzle box, but an expression
of values, and mods are just one of the ways
in which that manifests.
For all the drama that can be wrung from Golub’s
writing, his conclusion is not a tirade against
mods or those who use them.
Instead, Golub sees this as evidence that
virtual worlds are made compelling not by
their fiction, but from their reality.
World of Warcraft is the product of the emergent
collusion of developers and players, social
practices go a huge way toward defining how
we got to this point.
To lay the blame at the feet of, just, players
as a collective, to argue that the game would
be improved if only Microsoft’s Activision-Blizzard-King
just had the control it needed to realize
its creative vision.
Mm.
Not loving that.
World of Warcraft is an emergent culture that
is constituted by its players, its inhabitants
if you want to be romantic.
Modern World of Warcraft is a mess in a way
that only humanity could create.
It is full of contradiction and hypocrisy,
it rewards our worst impulses, before demanding
payment in full.
Certain anthropologists feared that WoW’s
nature as a game would undermine its value
as a site for cultural study, that incentivising
behaviors would generate inauthentic data.
But this feels plenty authentic to me.
Golub suggests that in the face of digital
spaces we retire the concept of the “real”
world, especially as the idea is posed in
opposition to the virtual, where experiences
in one are true while experiences in the other
are false, fake, or fictive, that whatever
happens online it’s not real.
This framing neglects to encompass the very
real humans who utilize these spaces, bringing
with them all their human attributes, their
drama, the tangle of their lives.
Virtual spaces are not apart from the world
but an extension of it, and to this Golub
suggests a much tamer distinction between
the virtual world and the actual world, demoting
the physical to a mere subset of reality.
“The key feature of the actual world which
virtual worlds must share with it in order
to become compelling is not its visual and
sonic “realism,” but the fact it is a
forum in which we give our lives meaning by
entangling them in projects we undertake with
others.
Worlds become real when we care about them,
not when they look similar to our own”.